let's do something definitely what
should we do you can't do it do what
what we're doing why does bailey madison
look so familiar
probably because we watched her grow up
on screen from the time she was seven
the upcoming netflix film a week away
marks madison's return to the screen
but where has the child star been in the
meantime why did she leave her major
role on good witch
what other passions has she been
pursuing i want to come
you can't it's a free country
there's a certain sparkle in bailey
madison's eyes that's so familiar but
why can't we figure out where we've seen
her before the fact is we haven't seen
her in anything for a couple of years
which is actually quite a long time
since she's been acting since she was so
young
the powerhouse actress was the adorable
face in popular films and tv shows over
the years like bridge to terabithia
just go with it brothers wizards of
waverly place
the fosters and good witch seeing her
all grown up in the trailer for the new
netflix film a week away totally caught
us off guard
so how exactly did her extensive
hollywood career begin
it was so much fun yeah it was great
she's pretty much been raised on set
since she was in commercials from the
time she was still in a stroller
her mom and sister are both actors so
her entry into the industry was pretty
natural
i thought you'd be excited to have an
acting job if it's an acting job we
should get paid
her career really started when madison
was in the waiting room while her sister
auditioned for the film lonely hearts
and the team saw her waiting and asked
if she'd be interested in auditioning
for a role they needed to fill
she did the audition with her sister
reading opposite and the rest is history
i didn't even know what was happening
just a year later she received her first
of many award nominations for her guest
role on the tv show house
she may be only 21 but madison is
skilled and mature beyond her years
since she grew up acting it's been her
form of school in a lot of ways
graduating from the different stages of
her career thus far she's in pretty good
company considering she's worked with
the likes of salma hayek jake gyllenhaal
natalie portman jennifer aniston and
countless other a-list actors who've
become both her colleagues and family
madison demonstrated her skill and
stamina with her leading role in good
witch
a show she worked on for five seasons
that's a long time for any actor but
especially someone at such a formative
age it's especially hard to be
wouldn't eat and figuring stuff out she
left the show in 2019 but there wasn't
any negative reason surrounding the
decision
the choice was simply because it was
time to move on and explore different
projects
when it came to making sure she could
stay level-headed in the industry her
family took great care in how they
approached the career
madison actually wouldn't even get the
chance to read a role until it was
vetted and approved by both her sister
and mom first
it's easy for young actors to face
struggles and grow up too quickly in
hollywood
so her family made sure to limit her
work to projects that were age
appropriate and allowed her to still be
a kid
this wound up resulting in some roles
being turned down but definitely didn't
have a negative impact on her career
this is definitely a contributor to her
vulnerable and truthful performances
over the years
it's her birthday honey i didn't get
anything that i wanted my birthday
now that she's returning to the screen
as an adult will see her take on a
mature role as the supposedly perfect
girl at a christian summer camp
i'm like trying to be what everybody
expects me to be
it's not only her acting resume that's
extensive
bailey madison's talents are so varied
that she doesn't just have other hobbies
and interests but
full-blown careers after spending so
many years in front of the camera her
transition to a producing role made
total sense
she was only 15 years old when she acted
as a producer and actor for the film the
strangers pray at night
an experience she's noted as one of the
most cherished in her life
seeing the inner workings of how a
production was put together was
fascinating for madison and she grew
deep appreciation for the process
inspiring her to contribute directly to
it herself she's noted reese witherspoon
is one of her inspirations so
who knows maybe she'll follow in her
footsteps and start her own production
company
outside of the film world madison holds
the professional titles of author
and fashion designer while she was on
set doing one of her many projects she
somehow found the time to co-write a
book with her friend and colleague
stephanie miller called losing brave
a book by and for teens what did you say
to me
i was like would you ever want to write
a book and i was like let's write a book
always thinking ahead towards other
possibilities madison wrote the book
with the idea of potentially turning it
into a screenplay or mini-series in mind
anyone looking to exude her impeccable
style can check out her fashion line at
macy's
her collaboration with them and nowadays
was a big step for her and fulfilled a
lifelong dream
it's always been a dream of mine to step
into the fashion industry madison has
actually been drafting clothing designs
for years
she also collaborated with nick's teen
to promote a wireless adjustable bra
that's delivered with a positive message
to uplift and support teenagers
to love and enjoy and feel good about
themselves in
her diverse portfolio makes her an
incredible role model for young people
and adults alike
watching the trailer for a week away we
can see her singing and dancing
something we definitely hope to see more
of from her she's been giving us
some sneak peeks on her social media of
her budding musicality with videos of
herself playing ukulele and singing
we absolutely adore this taylor swift
cover
as for her future pursuits madison is
planning to spend more time behind the
camera and is hoping to direct something
soon as well
that is when she's not too busy pursuing
her other interests like philanthropy
travel and who knows what else juggling
so many careers and wearing so many
hats it's no wonder we didn't recognize
her right off the bat we can't wait to
see how she continues to grow in all of
her pursuits
from what we can tell it seems like this
is just the beginning
more so than her fashion line it feels
like her positive outlook and
inspirational messages are her signature
look
as i always say you're never too young
to make a difference and that's really
true
in 2019 bayley madison was a speaker at
we day
an event filled with inspiring people
promoting positivity and working towards
making change
it's important to acknowledge the
struggles that madison has faced growing
up
the challenge of simply being a public
figure from the time she was so young
and having her entire life set under a
microscope is pressure enough
a few years ago some online trolls
called her a prude
and instead of letting it get her down
she spoke up about it and wrote an
inspirational essay on tumblr that wound
up causing an
entire social media movement called
hashtag
i'm more than a word it seems as though
madison is able to take any scenario in
her life and turn it into a positive
her maturity and level-headedness shone
through when she was dating her
boyfriend alex lang
he was quick to share his love for her
but madison waited a full six months
before she told him that she loved him
which can be a long time for teenagers
experiencing a relationship for the
first time
love at first sight for the whole family
in terms of big stars and living up to
the pressure of being in the
entertainment industry
madison has followed sage advice from
her mother she practices seeing people
as human beings instead of stars and
as a result she's built many
relationships with her colleagues and
some have grown to be like family for
her
part of her success has also definitely
come from having an incredible support
system
she's very close with her family and has
said that the women in her life inspire
and motivate her
her mom and sister in particular
remember when we said some of her
colleagues became like family
well this was definitely true for selena
gomez who she did wizards of waverly
place with
the two are still very close and madison
considers her a mentor and big sister
it's nice to be kind of the little one
in the business growing up and getting
to have a lot of
beautiful big sisters to get to look up
to a factor that likely plays into
madison's success is her prioritizing
having fun
she enjoys all of the work she does and
has said that she wants to continue
pursuing all those avenues until she
isn't having fun anymore
at which point she would move on sage
and wise advice from such a young person
i have a lot of fun i'm very blessed as
for what to do when she's struggling and
feeling low
madison credits practicing being humble
grateful for all that she has in her
life and making sure to give it her all
each and every day i truly believe that
if we all join together we can make a
difference
while she has so many plates spinning
we're so excited to know that bailey
madison hasn't left the screen for good
we're eager to see her take on more
adult roles as she gets older and her
work behind the camera once she dives
into directing
when she isn't too busy designing
writing and inspiring that is